all right hey folks welcome to the panel
in the future of human ai collaboration
i'm erin halfacre and today i'll be your
chair
when we think about the future of
productive work it goes without question
that ai will be important from news
feeds to tech suggestions ais are
playing a greater role in how we consume
information how we communicate and how
we work
in this panel we'll be exploring
questions about how we should build a
future that brings the best of humans
and ai together in collaboration
note that this is intended not to be a
prediction or a forecast instead i
invite the panelists to help us consider
what direction and goals we should focus
on in our work
first we'll kick things off with a round
of introductions and position statements
and then we'll dig into five exploratory
questions that the other organizers and
i have prepared for the panelists i hope
you're informed by the discussion
and with that we'll kick things off with
jamie's introduction
thanks erin um yes so my name is jamie t
van and i'm chief scientist at microsoft
so
that means that i'm responsible for
driving research-backed innovation in
microsoft's core products such as office
and windows and teams
and not surprisingly it also means that
i think a lot about how ai is changing
the way that people work
and one of the things that i think is
interesting
to reflect on is we sometimes make the
mistake of thinking that ai
is this magic secret sauce that we can
just sprinkle onto existing work
practices
and make everything easier and better
but that's not really
what it is um ai is just a new tool it's
a powerful tool but it's a tool
and it's one that people are going to
have to figure out how to work with and
here at microsoft we very much view it
as our responsibility to ensure that
it's a great tool
so what does that mean
to work effectively with ai
um people are gonna have to work a
little bit differently you know the
tools that we use they shape
what we do and they shape how we're able
to do what we do
and people also care a lot about the
tools that they work with and they're
going to want to for example
be in charge of what an ai system learns
versus
just having the system learn without
their actively being involved in it
and so that means the question of how to
make ai
the tool
work well for us is really a deeply
human question and so it's a pleasure to
be here
with you all today talking about that
topic
so just hopping in here to say that uh
bill stacey here who is originally
planning to be on this panel regretfully
couldn't uh
be with us today
but i just wanted to take the
opportunity to highlight uh one of the
things that bill wanted us to focus on
which is the opportunity for
transparency around ai regretfully i
don't think i'll be able to capture his
thoughts for us but maybe we can
consider that as we answer the questions
that we have
all right
chan
hi everyone um
i am qian yang i am an assistant
professor at cornell
my research area is human ai in action
design and mostly in medicine and in
natural language generation
um for today's panel i would like to
start with the provocation
um i envision a future
of ai
um that's um
that makes ai as unremarkable as
as electricity
i envision a future where ai infuses our
lives and society is
in valuable ways just like electricity
this means i think at least two things
one is ai is valuable in many different
ways in all aspects of society just like
electricity and we want to leverage that
power but on the other hand
electricity can be dangerous
but engineers and designers are able to
create infrastructures
applications and human interfaces that
protect users in our
different communities from these
potential risks and i hope that we can
create a future
where ai is just like electricity where
we
ai engineers and designers can protect
our users and societies from their risks
as well
and i very much look forward to the
discussion with everyone
thanks jan and last but not least
charles
so thank you for that i i one of the
great things about uh going last is that
you get to agree with everything that
everyone said and said that that's
exactly what you are going to say and
that uh you think that everything is
interesting and you get to pick fights
if that's what you want to do so let me
just start by saying i'm charles isbell
i'm a professor and the
dean of the college of computing at
georgia tech i've been living in the
world of ai and machine learning for far
longer than i'm willing to admit and
mostly i've been spending time thinking
about decision making and thinking about
what we call interactive artificial
intelligence this notion of building uh
teams of human beings and and
intelligent agents and building those
intelligent agents where they're going
to have to live with thousands tens of
thousands hundreds of thousands of other
intelligent agents only some of whom
might be human the conclusion that i've
sort of come through over the years and
thinking about this is that this notion
of human ai collaboration what we're
talking about really
in order to be successful
hinges on taking very seriously the
phrase itself the taking very seriously
the idea that the human matters the ai
matters and that the collaboration
itself matters and what we have been
doing wrong in some sense uh is that we
have been thinking about it purely from
the humans point of view or even
thinking purely about it as a as a
notion of tool rather than thinking
about it as a kind of long-term and sort
of ultimate partnership and where we see
this is issues of ethics where we see
this as negative impacts of what the
tools we are building
do and and how they impact the rest of
the world and the only way or add a
important way which we're going to get
around that is to make it better and
what i would hope to talk about here
today is in treating the entire pipeline
uh
as a significant and first-class citizen
that we have to think about the people
who are at the end the end users we have
to think about the people who are going
to be touched by this we have to have
them in the room at the very beginning
and we have to think about the whole
system instead of doing what so many of
us want to do myself included which is
focus narrowly on the little bit of part
where the data magically appears and my
model magically appears on the outside
and there there are no consequences to
that so if we can get past that we will
make huge strides for it and the future
that i think we all want to have
all right great thanks folks and thank
you for being so timely with your
introductions and position statements
um so next we're going to uh a set of
questions again as i mentioned in the
introduction i want you to focus on the
should you know it's great to make
predictions but predictions are really
hard and i think that you all have some
really good inter uh points of views on
should
also consider responsibility who has it
what how that applies in these systems
and also if you can bring in any
concrete examples that can help our
audience understand what we're trying to
get at when we talk about theoretical
things that we might like so the first
question that i want to ask the panel is
how should we combine human agency with
ai support so that the whole is greater
than the sum of the parts
what should ai not do what should people
not do
and feel free to jump in
well i'll i'll start uh and maybe uh
i'll be more provocative than i
necessarily need to be and we can have a
nice conversation about this so uh i
take issue with the premise of the
question uh so you know you're
describing it as uh the the human has
agency uh and the ai is the support but
i think it's just as reasonable to talk
about the ai having agency and the human
having support not because um i think
that ai is this magical thing that we're
going to create but that it's important
to think of these entities that we are
creating these tools that we are using
as ones that will exist in the world
autonomously and will have impact and
that is just as important for the human
beings to see themselves as supporting
the development of the tool as it moves
through the world as it is to think of
the tool as supporting us i think that a
mistake that we make
sometimes and it's very easy to make is
to think of ourselves as programming
this system maybe by example or thinking
about the way we develop ai with this
language or that language or by feeding
it this piece of data or using this
particular algorithm so that the object
at the end is a thing that's going to
help us to solve a problem but it's
actually more interesting to think about
it as a kind of
idiot savant something that is going to
be excellently good at a thing and our
job is to help it to develop to be
excellently good at that thing and tend
to solve the problem in a way that we
are not going to be able to solve the
problem as a human being to try to build
something that will be uh interesting
and good at doing that and so i think
the nature of the question what it means
to do better than the sum of your parts
is to remember that each of those parts
are kind of independently uh important
and capable of doing interesting things
that perhaps the the other parts are not
but that question of is it a tool that
is supporting us and solving the problem
we care about or are we trying to help
it to get to the point where it is
solving a particular problem that'll be
useful for the the group is i think an
important one that we're not programming
it we are teaching it and that's a
fundamental difference between building
an ai or building a machine learning
system versus
uh
you know building a slightly faster
sorting algorithm
i think it's a fair point although i
would say it's ultimately still to be
solving the problems that we care about
it's just a longer term view it's how do
we help the tool actually evolve in a
way
that is you know going after what we're
trying to accomplish and um you know and
you sort of you bring this up too that
the key to the the key to this question
is that artificial intelligence is
different from human intelligence it's
not like a dumb human it's a thing that
does something differently um
and there are things that are impossible
for people to do
that that ai can do you know there's no
way
that we as people would look at every
single document on the web and see if
it's related to some query but a search
engine can do that really easily
um and likewise there are mistakes that
ai is going to make that people want
there are things that ai can do that
people can't you know it's easy for me
to come up with search queries that
match a long-term need that i have or
help help move things forward and search
engines can't do that and so one of the
things that we really need to be doing
is to think about the unique and
complementary ways that ai solves
problems and that people think about
things and then thinking you know to
your point thinking that about how do we
go in and lean in and maximize
both of those things so like ai is good
at finding patterns and it's good at
applying them at scale uh on the other
hand people are good at drawing
connections and we're good at critical
thinking we're good at seeing holes or
where things don't work
ai's good at the things that people
don't want to do or that we don't want
to have to do over and over again or
that are too dangerous
uh for us to do um
and i do think that there are um you
know there are great examples of where
you actually do have things coming
together to behave in in better ways
than um than we currently
do and that and it certainly does
reflect what you are saying charles
about both um the system growing over
time and the individuals
learning how to how to participate in
that interaction as well so search
engines are a great illustration of that
i think of the opportunity um
to have ai do what it's good at and
people do what it's good at and you know
we all have better access to information
because of the different strengths that
artificial and human intelligence bring
to the table there
yeah i absolutely agree and i think
search engine is such a great example
for that kind of human ai complement
charity um i also want to just add one
sort of meta point i think
this conversation about what machines
should do and what humans should do and
should how do we divide up the workload
in our societies it's a long
conversation that has happened all over
i don't think the human ai collaboration
question is
that
that fundamentally different from from
human machine collaboration more
probably but i think there's also this
larger question about who should have
this conversation should we people who
build ai
or design ai systems make that
conversation um have that conversation
and decide which ai should do
should the end users have a say in
whether there should be ai or not at all
when a patient goes to see a doctor
do they have a say in whether they're
they want to go through a sort of
sorting algorithm first or not i think
that sort of meta conversation
um is quite distinctive to to the
to the time we're living in where
there's a lot of debate on
whether there's certain fields should
have ai at all and how should we divide
up workload or divide up the role of
human and ai in a sort of meta sense
fantastic this is a wonderful segue to
the next question
but first i want to give the panel
points on pulling in uh examples i
really appreciate how you all talked
about search and that's that's great i
want to see more of that
um so the next question is who should
decide what an ai learns to the point
that jan was making uh who's responsible
for the consequences and how do we make
the consequences beneficial and who
benefits
well i guess i'll just start by saying
um more cons pretty consistent to what i
was saying earlier i think end users and
stakeholders and the broader publics
hopefully will have
more and more say in the kind of ai
especially ai in critical domains and
public
domains
that we hope hopefully we see
more of that conversation and more
participation
in the shaping of ai
so i i think it's a really interesting
question who decides and i think that
the way you get to an answer to that is
you realize that this is not a question
to to a point that was made earlier this
is not a question that is unique to ai
we have to ask these questions all the
time who gets to decide uh how something
gets built or how it gets deployed those
are big large societal questions the
difference i think the fundamental
difference here is the same difference
that computing brings to us generally
speaking not just ai it's scale it you
know when the question before is well
who gets to do this thing who gets to
use this and you're talking on the order
of the 10 people in the room uh or the
people in the small village are going to
be impacted by it you can have this kind
of conversation among a group of people
who have shared experiences and you kind
of understand what it is you're trying
to accomplish what we're seeing now
search engines are a great example of
this because they touch everyone and
everything and they look at data from
everyone and everything you're now
talking about the consequences of the
systems that you build touching
literally billions of people which means
that the answer to the question is the
same all of the people who are impacted
all of the stakeholders have to be a
part of that conversation it's just a
more difficult conversation to have
because you're not only talking about a
billion people instead of 10 you're
talking about a billion people with
radically different experiences
radically different cultures and
radically different
expectations and somehow we have to
figure out how to bring those people in
to be a part of this conversation
because otherwise we build systems that
make sense to the four people here but
they don't make sense to the 400 000
people who are going to actually be
impacted by it and you know i'll just
i'll i'll take an example that has sort
of
been in the community for a couple of
years now something simple like pulse
which is an amazing little little uh
piece of work that was out there uh that
had this wonderful uh impact on the sort
of wonderful ability to take pixelated
things and create new things out of it
and yet you know five minutes after it
gets out in the wild someone notices
that it turns non-white people into
white people and there's an interesting
question of how in the world would that
have happened and the answer is it
wasn't something that was intentional
it's just that the set of people in the
room to whom it would have occurred that
maybe we should look at this test case
weren't in the room and the consequences
of this really simple thing is huge and
problematic and you know it's a it's a
really big deal and that's actually a
pretty benign
outcome for not having the right people
in the room so anyway the answer to your
question i think is it's the same as it
is for any other piece of technology
everybody who's going to be impacted by
it it's just that now that's a lot of
everybody
and i um i love what you're doing there
charles too of thinking about
what is um what is making ai unique or
what sort of what brings us to consider
new things and scale is one and another
one i'll actually harken back to a point
you made for the for the first question
that i think is is important
is that people actually shape the system
as they use it
so it means as much as there are ai
modelers or developers who are
responsible uh for what the system is
looking like actually through our usage
the end user is responsible as well but
not always intentionally and not always
in a way that's aware and this is where
um having bill stacey are here perhaps
with his uh with that point he was gonna
make her own transparency um
matters as well um and
you know ai systems learn towards an
objective right and a lot of times that
objective is not something that that we
control for and um you know when we're
a great example of this is when we're
thinking about optimizing uh for
engagement right then it drives weird
behaviors and you know the system learns
how what engages me and then i go engage
with the system because it's engaging
and i reinforce that that um that
way of uh that interaction that the
system creates you know because i
get outraged by ridiculous headlines or
i get um interested in something that
causes a lot of emotion and then that
causes me causes the system and so like
i think the more we can start thinking
about how to get intentional about
actually the objectives that ai systems
are working towards as well um so i
think i think these are these are the
ways that we can start thinking about
how to um what what makes ai special and
how do we shape it in the world um that
we're existing in
if i could just add one thing to that i
think that you know and and you know
it's easy for me to to say this at this
point in my life but i think that uh it
requires humility on the part of people
like us right that you know we we think
we know what the right answer is we
think we're doing the right thing but of
course we don't we can't think through
the consequences of you know engagement
is going to yield all of these dominoes
are going to fall and i just have to
worry about engagement and you know the
sort of slavish attention to you know
predictive accuracy for example without
worrying about the consequences or even
asking the question of whether that's
the right thing that we should be
maximizing and the humility will make us
better programmers that make us better
engineers that make us better developers
and they'll lead to much better
questions it's better research
everything about it is better if we
remember that there's this larger set of
people outside of our own experiences
but you know that is hard right it is
hard to answer the question of who's
responsible who gets to make the
decision because not only there's so
many of them but there are also so many
of them who don't agree with me
um and figuring out how to deal with
that is i think a kind of fundamental
uh
process problem uh that we uh that we
have together and that harkens to the
point aaron that you were making and
just setting up the whole conversation
too that it's hard to predict the future
um and i think there's this really
important piece there that it's hard to
predict the future and it's hard to know
where things are going but it's also our
responsibility and we have to figure
that out because there are these um
these unintended consequences in the
things that we do and um you know i
think you raise a great point there
about two the importance of really
thinking broadly and who do we bring
into the room um you know and that's
thinking about the people who are being
impacted and the different stakeholders
it's thinking about um you know
different disciplines and different ways
of approaching problems and looking at
problems um
as well
you know again this is a wonderful segue
into the next question uh which is about
process and how we how we build and
maintain these kind of technologies
so uh how should we develop software
products to be adapted to working with
ai
can agile programming or lean
development methodologies be adapted to
working with ai
what new maintenance concerns should we
plan for and what issues does aia create
or solve with regard to software
development or user experience
i can i just say one thing you left out
explicitly which is the thing that i
worry about is how does debugging work
uh you know if you you is the system
wrong or is the system learning and what
does that even mean and how would you
ever know and if you know we're living
in a non-markovian universe and the
world is continually changing you know
how do you even know when you're done
the answer probably is you you never are
but you can't let the perfect be the
enemy the good so you have to deploy and
just think that it basically never ends
you're just constantly updating and
adapting and that's okay it's a it's
it's a part of the process i i think
that i don't have a great answer to that
other than i believe that the software
engineers and the programming languages
people have a lot to tell the machine
learning engineers about thinking about
an entire system it is a design problem
and it is a big thing that involves from
the very beginning thinking about what
the output is going to be and i think
that's that's quite difficult for for
for some of us to do but i will say one
thing that i do think uh is is at least
you know for me a kind of interesting
way of of thinking about this which is
to remember that it's very easy to fall
into the trap of thinking about tool
sets
and skill sets and forgetting that what
you actually care about is mindsets and
the real mindset here is to think about
this sort of notion of constantly
changing and adapting systems and that
has to be built in from the very
beginning of of how you design and so
then
if you think about it that way it's less
about how do i
program an ai and it's more about what
does it mean to have an adaptive system
that is growing and programming itself
so the end result is not the machine
learning model or the ai system that i
am programming it is that there is a set
of things that lead to uh adaptive
systems that will be solving a problem
so the ai the machine learning is the
programming language or the programming
mechanism or the specification uh the
way in which you specify what it is
you're trying to accomplish it is the
tool that gets you it's the means that
gets you to get you to the end is not
the end
and that
would help especially if you think about
it that way then you realize i should be
talking about this in cs 101. there's
anything about this in data science 101
i should be thinking about this much
earlier on it's not a thing that happens
at the end after i've figured out how
you know c sharp and python work
together or they don't
um yeah i i want to
i want to make two points
here one is sort of following up uh
charles points about how
ai
changes deep again she just changes
software engineering uh
in the first place and from
my perspective as an ux designer and
researcher
i think ai absolutely changes ux design
practices as well
designers are good at thinking about
what human needs are
what people with human agency problems
but we are now also dealing with these
constantly evolving and adapting systems
that
adapt at a massive scale how do we scale
human
empathy in our work
and how do we bring human considerations
to bear in these constantly adaptive
systems i think these absolute changes
these considerations absolutely change
how ux designers
work with engineers and work with
modelers
and i also want to make a simple point
which sort of connects to the
conversation we had in the last question
in the last question we talked about
participation we really want to bring in
all kinds of communities that are
impacted by ai but we also want to deal
with scale and we want to deal with
these constantly evolving systems and
the results of all these factors
combined is that it's really
difficult if possible at all to
maintain a certain level of
participatory design
in the ai development and maintenance
and sort of constant debugging and
evolving process
so how do we design
sort of proxies or sort of fallback
strategies
to maintain certain level of
participation
while realizing with this awareness that
this is it's very difficult
to to to be fully participatory in the
shaping of these systems i think these
are challenges um
uh that we're facing in ai development
and maintenance as well
yeah now and building on that you know
ai infrastructure is inherently human
right you can't have good ai
without the people
involved um you know it's a human
problem and it absolutely means that
design
and engineering and model development
need to be um
need to be tightly coupled and the fact
that it's deeply interaction based and
that it evolves is hard you know
a lot of times we try to we try to mock
up uh ai systems by like wizard of oz
approaches where you just have a person
acting in the back but that's you know
the mistakes aren't the same it's hard
to see those mistakes it's hard to see
the externalities it's hard to see the
ways that it'll go wrong
um one of the things i think we really
need to
to do in the context of ai one of the
things that's interesting about ai is
it's not deterministic it's pro
probabilistic you don't know what's
going to happen exactly it's not going
to behave in expected manners and that's
not that's not a bug of the system
that's the way it works right um and one
of the things that i find useful for me
is to think very much
about how to learn from mistakes and so
a lot of times you'll be sitting in um
seeing product demos or new features
that are about to ship
and uh it'll be amazing right like it'll
be like oh imagine you wanted this thing
to happen and it all happens magically
and it's awesome
and one of the things that i always do
there is to um to ask them to show me
when it fails what happens when the
system gets it wrong and um that's going
to happen that's like an inherent part
of the system and we need to be actively
designing um for the system to fail and
to not have those be to have those be
opportunities for learning opportunities
for um for for sharing knowledge and
also uh for people to teach the system
um
and uh also
you know they need to not cause
disasters or big problems
the failures are not failures if you do
them right right exactly make them not
failures
you know i've i've actually got us a
little bit of ahead of time so i want to
ask a little bit of a probe here because
it feels like we're pushing on like on
one side you can develop systems that
learn you know learn from mistakes learn
from uh um interaction and so you might
be able to deal with you know a bug by
having the user show the system
something or something like that but on
the other hand you know we have this
human infrastructure that maintains
these ai systems and the software that
they exist in and so i wonder how you
see like the the trade-off like do we
need both will we eventually develop
technologies that just learn enough
where we don't we need less human
infrastructure is the human
infrastructure always going to be part
of this
i would hope so because the whole point
of the exercise is to to improve the
human condition right
i mean i don't know this this feels like
i mean i like the question i mean i'm
not dismissing the question but this
feels a lot like you know does a tree
fall in the forest and no one's there to
hear it
does it make a sound and you know if the
the ai is learning and there's no human
being to benefit or be affected by it
does it does it really matter and i
think the answer is we're trying to
solve human scale problems we're trying
to solve solve problems that are going
to affect us and make things better so i
would hope that humans would have to be
a part of the process and the same
forever in exactly the same way that we
have to be as we as human beings solve
our own problems anyway or maybe i
misunderstood the question but i think
that's
fundamental and important
or we don't matter anymore and the ai's
have gone off on their own in which case
i don't i don't know how to answer that
i would also think that human
infrastructure would always be part of
the ai but then the question is again
knowing that
simply taking human into accounts
through their data through their
interaction traces it's not that's not
enough that we we have learned over time
that
if we simply think oh the data that
each person contributes is the
represents that person's desire that's
too simplistic and actually causes
biases and other issues
um so the question is really upon this
human infrastructure what do we do how
do we take into account these
these inputs
and i think
jimmy raises really good point like
these systems learn so if we can
leverage these data inputs really well
we can actually really make good and
make the system better but i think
there's also the other part that like
for example
language models nowadays are becoming
increasingly just gigantic
and if we simply assume that oh if this
person can this one user can correct
that in action by giving one more data
point and that can correct the issue of
gpd2 gpd3 i think
there's really a weight problem there
and we need to
really
so trying to balance these and i think
that's the more difficult question
against the backdrop of that human
infrastructure
great
okay so moving on to what i think is
maybe the hardest question of this panel
uh depending on well maybe you all have
thought about it more than me
uh
how should ai create or evolve jobs
or how should this impact communities
companies and individuals
so i think this harkens back to the
first question that we were talking
about um
where we need to think about what the
unique value that people bring to the
table you know it is thinking about this
you know
how how do
ai systems and people work together um
to get to good end goals um and and then
when you think about that you know the
impact of the future of what people
contribute it's really bringing out
that those aspects that are special um
about that you know
ai is essentially just pattern matching
right based on data and you get a bunch
of examples and it figures out how to
how to repeat them but the system only
learns the patterns we teach it so that
becomes like when you start thinking
about uh what people with human
intelligence do our job is to figure out
where those patterns might exist
um you know an ai system can't learn for
example
that a problem might be
solved well with imagery if it's a large
language model that's only been trained
on text and it's up for us up to us to
make those connections
um
ai systems are lazy they learn the very
first pattern that they that they see um
they only find once they find a pattern
that works that's good enough that's it
right so
um you know that i think a good
canonical example there is thinking
about um
training actually for hiring related to
jobs like i have a large stack of
resumes and i'm processing uh those
resumes to figure out who i should
interview
and i've trained it on um
existing resumes of software developers
who are really good and most software
developers are male so the system
quickly learns that words like father or
his
indicate that this person might be a
good software developer and that's not
accurate and
you know you and i know that words like
that aren't important for hiring a good
software developer um but the system
doesn't and so that means that people's
job is to challenge the system and ask
questions and we provide value by seeing
the mistakes and the failures and
working there you know as we were just
talking about learning from those
failures making them opportunities to
grow um
you know i also think about
ai systems uh create a push towards the
normative by encouraging us to repeat
patterns that we've seen before
and
the advances in language models are a
great example here again you know think
about text auto completion um are we all
going to start writing our emails
exactly the same way
and to fight that push towards the
normative our job as people um starts
becoming how do we do things differently
how do we see things in new ways you
know how do we do things that don't fit
the pattern
and a thoughtful system can create space
for us to do that but it's you know
people's job to find those um find those
patterns
yeah i think there's kind of a negative
and a positive answer so the negative
answer is you know the problem with ai
is that they're computers and the
problem with computers is they do what
we tell them to do in fact they do
exactly what we tell them to do
far more efficiently than we can do it
and so a lot of what will continue to
happen is we will teach things to do
what we tell them to do and then we will
discover we've meant to do something
else and we will constantly be finding
the problem that we're actually trying
to solve and constantly constantly um
trying to trying to refine it and do
something new that's kind of the
negative way of thinking about it um i
think the positive way of putting it if
i can
abuse the notion
maslow's hierarchy right i tend to think
of it as being infinite right as you get
more and more freedom to think about
more and more things you think of more
and more things to do and those things
to do are often positive
and so i think the future for humans in
the future for work in a world where we
really do automate away a lot of things
is that it freezes up to worry about
other things that are more interesting
which generates more problems more
interesting things to do which allows us
to automate those and then to do more
and more and more and more and we stop
worrying about i don't know chronic
diseases and and um and start worrying
instead about wellness and how to make
people live longer and better and
happier once we get past you know the
bottom of the the bottom of the pyramid
uh and i think that's going to be the
the kind of future is it allows us in
the in a positive world and you know
this sounds
like you know i'm really really
optimistic about the world but and i
kind of am that you know if we do this
right it freezes up to find completely
new problems that we simply don't have
the time um or
um i don't know we just don't we don't
have the time and freedom to otherwise
find and and i think that is i think
that is great if we if we do it right so
it's positive i don't think we run out
of jobs
so uh maybe this this optimism pessimism
and anything in between is good for this
last question which is where would you
like to see human ai collaboration in 10
years time and what do we need to do now
to get there
i really loved this question i sort of
you
wrote my position
um slides with this question in mind i
think
um ai i think again like on the positive
side on the optimistic side i think ai
is just like electricity and like
jamie was saying
it's just a tool that helps people do
things that they're already doing so i
think we have the potential have the
ability to
craft systems and interfaces that
form these good human eye collaborations
and do do tasks better
but on the other
side
i think it's not to say
electricity is simply a tool does not
mean that if electricity does not
revolutionize societies and industries
automating like giving writing
suggestions may be fine in email writing
but it really has already revolutionized
use industry journalism so i think these
are these larger scale questions are the
challenges and that we need to deal with
i think in the next 10 years and
hopefully we can do it with that
positive with the optimistic side um in
hand as well yeah and i i mean i
certainly i yeah
i think this notion i think you're
exactly right that um you know we want
to get towards this positive future that
charles is outlining and it's going to
have
uh impact in ways that we don't see and
it's so hard to imagine in 10 years how
like the infrastructure that has changed
because of our systems able to able to
um you know identify and apply patterns
at scale and learn from interaction and
learn from data
to figure out new things
i imagine people have become experts in
teaching ai systems like we've been
talking to about and not just through
interaction or even through something
simple like labeling data you know
tagging photos on facebook or that sort
of thing but by actually setting the
system's goals and and shaping the
underlying models um
you know
i think we're going to see really
significant changes when when when
people are intentionally seeking out new
knowledge and rewarded for finding
different ways of looking at things when
they're sort of moving up to discover
these new questions and
and that that we need to answer um you
know i think there's there you know i
get excited when i think about how we're
going to enable the creation of rich
personal views of the world too what
does it you know right now a lot of the
models we're doing are because data and
and actually large scale data is so
important we're we're really learning um
about
societal things but you know what does
it mean to capture what a person has
learned over the lifetime or the wisdom
of a family or the intellectual property
of a company um and so i think there's
uh
though
that ability is gonna
is gonna change us just as fundamentally
as electricity has changed things for us
so by the way i love the i love the
electricity metaphor for a lot of
reasons and because it's ubiquitous and
because it feels unremarkable but of
course it's magic it's absolute magic
and it changes everything i'm sitting
here there's a light shining on me that
that makes it possible for you to see me
otherwise that would be more difficult
to do otherwise because it's a cloudy
day out here and all of that and that is
magic right it is magic i i what i see
in the future what i want to see is a
kind of invisible ubiquity of ai we
don't even think of it as remarkable
even as it is but that not at the scale
to take to take what jamie said not at
the kind of just at the scale of
everyone taken together
but at the scale of the very personal
and the very the very individual you
know when i was a grad student a hundred
twenty thirty years ago shortly after
they invented fire um i worked on this
um this video project i needed a four
hundred thousand dollar machine um it
took me all night to build what turned
out to be about four minutes of video
and it was fun it was great my daughter
when she was uh 11 years old put
together an award-winning uh five-minute
video with her phone and just her
imagination and the system was fixing
audio levels for her automatically it
was focusing in the right place and that
doesn't take away from what she was
doing uh it was still the cree it
enabled her to to be creative and and
what i want to imagine as i sit here
staring into four rectangles um and
talking to people who are in the future
right now uh that we
recognize that uh we are living in an
age of miracles that it's a very
personal age of miracles and they were
able to do things that we otherwise
would not have been able to do and just
accept it as the normal course of events
so that we can free our minds to think
about about other things so 10 years
from now i want to have an ai assistant
living with me all the time helping me
in various ways and helping me to to be
better and a much more interesting
person than i am now
wonderful thank you folks for a
wonderful panel that's all the time that
we have and uh thank you for everybody
who attended thank you
you